my name is Ethan vana I work at Wolfram
and today I'm going to talk about how to
automatically distribution from beta
hi everyone thank you for coming to this
talk so my name is Etienne Barnard and
I'm going to talk about a new function
that will be there in version 12 of the
language that is called learn
distribution and the goal of this
function as its name indicates is to
learn a probability distribution from
from data so so actually so what kind of
data are we talking about so it could be
very simple data let's say I just have
lists of categorical variable that can
be a or b here learning the tribution
will just be about you know estimating
the frequency of each each possibility
it could be a numeric variable so an
example Instagram would be a way to
learn distribution from from this
uni-dimensional a numeric variable but
of course it can be also higher
dimension so here is an example in two
dimension well the goal will be to go
from this this data set of
two-dimensional values to a function
that can compute the PDF so the
probability density in that case for any
point of the space but of course we can
go further and and we can mix numerical
variable and no mean no viable so we
start to define distribution here on
data sets on classic structure data like
in that case where you have a class that
is a nominal and then you have the age
numerical and we can extend this notion
of distribution - let's say images or
text or audio and many other things so
that's the goal of learn distribution by
the way should one use trade away
currently is a text and audio and
everything that is viable sighs is it
won't be in 12 so it's going to be the
next version but but image and all that
other stuff will work okay so why do we
want to learn
distribution well I like to say it's a
holy grail of unsupervised learning
because probably the hardest task to
actually assess the distribution
especially when you're high dimensional
data set and you can do a lot of things
with the distribution the most
straightforward thing is to generate new
examples okay which maybe might be
useful
another of its application and actually
you can use random variate with
distribution will that will show after
another important application is anomaly
detection since you have a function to
compute the probability mass or perfect
density of the data then you can if
someone gives you a new example you can
compute this probability and if it's
very very low well it's a sign that it
doesn't been sampled so to speak from
the distribution that you learn it's
it's out of distribution sample it's an
outlier and that's how you can you can
tell that it's anomaly and we have a
function that is called a detection in
12 there is a based on a distribution
and Amir is going to talk about it in a
in an hour so you can also predict any
variables as function of others because
when you have a distribution you can
condition it you can say okay I know
that X Y Z equal to this value so what
is the value of G can you predict T as
function of the other so it's a bit like
a classifier or predictor but I can work
for any variables so here you can see
that the tasks that is to solve that is
when you can get that it's task is more
complex than just a classifier that
focused on predicting one variable here
it's kind of a predictor that focus on
predicting any variable and because you
can predict any variable you can for
example fill in missing values if I
train a distribution I give a new
example there's some missing values you
can condition the distribution on the
values that you know and let's say
sample the value that you don't know or
find the most likely value the values
that you don't know and and there would
be a function in 12 as well synthesized
missing values
and there's other things so you can do
for example denoising or error
correction this won't be in 12 this was
still trying to figure out how we can
make that efficient but here the idea is
let's say I have a distribution and I
have a data point that is corrupted in
some way so I'm know some error some
corruption and how can I make this so it
will actually be considered an anomaly
like if I pass it through any detector
it will say well the PDF of this thing
is too low it's an anomaly so the goal
of the noising i mean at least that's
one way to formalize it will be to make
this sample back into the distribution
so so one way we could do it at least
conceptually is to take this core sample
and then try to climb the PDF so trying
to go in let's say with the gradient
ascent to make the probability of the
sample more likely and as soon as it
reach probability that is okay then we
say all right that's that's corrected
example a dinos example so so that's
another application that should follow
from anis tribution although this one is
a bit harder to put in practice then you
can of course ask for expectations or
probing is you can say well have my
distribution so what is the probability
that I don't know ages above 30 and
sexes female and person I don't remember
what was that I said that I was showing
and the person survived can you compute
that so you can do this sort of queries
probablistic queries and there many many
others you can do so we are not going to
support many of these at first but I
hope they will come later find viable at
share information so that's so you know
usually if you want to know if two
variables are of some share information
usually do a simple correlation linear
correlation and this is quite brittle
because you can have variables that are
that share a lot of information but are
not linearly Caleta correlated so so one
way to that will be to compute which
mutual information which requires
modeling distributions and and
this again is something we have to
experiment with but we should be able to
do mutual information function based
online distribution all right and
supervised learning is another another
application if you have data some a
label some are not labeled you can you
can actually treat that as a missing
value problem that the label that I'm
missing it's just another variable and
and you could learn the distribution on
this all set or you could do all sort of
of tricks to take advantage of this
unlabeled data and there's probably
other application that I haven't thought
of it's quite a powerful thing when you
have the distribution of data all right
so let me show you in practice len
distribution so let's start something
extremely simple all right just a
nominal space it was just five example
so you see you just give data set so
it's probably the simplest of the
machine learning functions because you
don't need to have labels and if
everything you just give data and and
then you say learn this version of this
data and it return to learn the
distribution note small differences we
haven't found a better name fortunately
it's a pretty similar and then you can
start doing things so I can I can do a
random variates which are whether
existing symbols that work on classic
distributions of the language so okay
just random variates
all right a great let's do 100 okay then
you can query the PDF so I can say what
is the probability of a okay well
something like this yes this is this is
independently sampled oh yes yes yes
okay okay true okay good good thing so
this one assumed independent samples
like classify predict and others we yeah
because there are some smoothing so so
yeah so the goal is to really generalize
to a test set it's not to try to you
know maximize the likelihood on on the
training set so so you will see thing
like that so here it will go I guess
what it should be it should be open for
you right and 0.42 it's because it's
assumed that it put a little bit of
smooth saying because it's you mean
that's not enough sample to okay but to
some exactly that that's it but but the
sum should be one son should be one and
so that okay two things you can do here
imputing missing value doesn't know much
interest where probability again I will
talk later okay so let's let's look at a
numerical space numeric space here so
two-dimensional that so when I was
showing before okay so let's do learn
distribution risk I should have put that
before whatever okay so it learn
distribution it was okay we didn't see
much Oh something I should show you is
that you can also have information about
the distribution in the same way as you
have this for for classifying predict by
the way in the past it was classified
information preeto information now for
twelve we kind of moving everything into
something called information but works
from basically everything in the
language so so when you can see a bit of
information here so it's a kernel
density estimation with Gaussian kernel
type isn't selected and so on you can
also have a clue of what's happening in
the automation so we'll talk about that
a bit later but it's the same type of
automation of a classifying predict
where the system perform experiments and
small training set and figure out what
works best on a small training set and
try to infer what would work best on the
big training set in order not to have to
try everything on the big training set
because it's slower to train on a big
training set and so that's why as a
by-product we have this learning curve
so with only something like an eight
example here this was the loss with such
example we were here with 200 we're here
and
is kind of learning curves for all the
algorithm that I've been tested so on a
multi normal has been tested contingency
table but kernel density estimation is
picked in the end okay so let's look at
the both the sample sampled sorry the
training data ends the estimated density
in that case okay so so it looks like
this and let's do for example as a just
to understand what's happening let's use
synthesize missing values on this
distribution where let's put 6 points:5
for now so the x value here is 6.5 and
the Y value is missing so really what's
going to happen is that the distribution
will condition itself on the fact that X
equal six point five and then sample
according to this condition distribution
so you should have resolved between 4
and 6 and all right something something
pretty close so you can see we can also
plot istagram or actually I put a 6.5
yes yes yes which is exactly exactly
which is I mean 0.42 it's a bit
different this was a for the training
but for specific case of imputing
missing values it will sample from the
conditional distribution which is very
important because then you can do that
many times and and see a bit the
confidence you have on your imputation
and also if you go and compute means or
compute some physical properties it's
useful to have a sample yes at the
moment it assumes that it is continuous
even if you have integers and this is a
very interesting question because in
practice people give data that are
rounded so if somebody gave it at a set
I mean actually what was an example yeah
Stephen often often try to learn the
distribution on his heartbeat and it's
always around into an integer you know
eighty nine bit per minutes you know and
so on and often you expect the system to
to understand this as a continuous
distribution and not a discrete
distribution so we haven't really solved
that problem I want to give a
possibility - if it's discrete you know
that it learned discrete but often I
would like this function to assume what
99% of the K is a user intended yes not
yet not yet
this is I will talk about it a bit later
I mean in the future
that's something I would like to but I
cannot yet okay so we can see here it
gives the istagram
if I put let's say 5.5 here we should
have a bimodal thing because five point
five is here so you can see in five
point five it should have that would be
the ego that's that's kind of that's
actually kind of the conditional
distribution of and oh by the way you
have a method so I can put method mode
finding Mart finding and this should but
these are approximate it tries to find
the mode so in that case it will be one
point five
actually it's still a little bit
stochastic in that case but it's
something that is much closer to the to
the mode because there's no exact way to
find the mode okay all right so let's
show another example this time on the
data sets so is numerical and no mean or
viable and missing values and you can
just learn the distribution on this and
alright so you can see how it actually
bit more time here so you can see the
learning curve in action and then I can
again run on valuates let's say ten
examples that's that's what that's
interesting it's actually a negative age
oh wow contingency table
huh I mean that said that's surprising
because I didn't figure out that the
thing was only positive but I'm
surprised by the magnitude normally it
shouldn't just be like this minus 0.01
or something like that I could I could
put so okay let's do this I could put
let's say you're not in a rush I'm going
to do 20 second and so here it will try
more models and hopefully there is all
we better than the first version that
took five second hopefully we won't have
negative value now yeah what okay no no
the system will infer that it is no no
in that case 1 2 3 it will figure out
it's a nominal variable not just because
it's a string if you put 1 2 3 have
integer it will figure out its nominal
and then maybe not the summary stick but
then you can force it with option
feature types you can say this features
no me no this feature is numerical yeah
yeah you can force it the other yeah I
thought you meant numeric but discrete
which is different all right so here I
can vary its hopefully in that case
there won't be any negative yes
oh yeah the ceiling is it okay well okay
I should check that I should check that
yeah and you can also ask for the PDF so
let's say these are the samples and I
can say a PDF I mean it's
all right
so let's let's continue oh yeah I'm sure
just hear it to example that out there
are with some missing values and I can
do synthesized missing values first
argument is the distribution and to
impute and they will be imputed okay and
you can also actually do that directly
in the data set it will learn a
distribution on the data set and then
impute everything if you do something
like that so I think in that case there
was only one value that was missing the
beginning here you can see this one but
this one so after 80 should be imputed
so actually you can see it's a 4.3 well
as you see it and to put that as a
numerical viable ends the 4.3 all right
so okay there's some some other random
examples I'm going to go quick on that
to talk about methods and other things
so let's say I'm distribution you can
ask for for PDF so you can see this one
is out of distribution and it's very
very low PDF Oh an interesting function
we introduced is a rarer probability
which is related to the PDF but actually
gives according to the distribution what
is the probability that this
distribution samples random sample an
example that has a lower PDF than this
example okay maybe a bit hard to wrap
your head around that it's kind of an
extension of p-value for arbitrary
dimension and that's really nice to
define anomalies it's kind of a anomaly
score it's it's what is the probability
to have an event that is rarer according
to the distribution even there is more
extreme according to the distribution so
if the probability is 10 minus 3 then
it's very very very unlikely to have
something rarer than what you gave so
it's probably an anomaly where if it's
something like if we take this one it's
probably going to be something around
0.5 let's see this is some things
and from the from the samples actually
so this probably is going to zero point
46 so it's just one chance out of 212
something more likely or less likely
yeah
no you don't need them
Oh in that case yes is yes sorry sorry
it's I think it's an RGB yes yes yes I
think that yes yes except the space is
not clearly defined so that's a bit of
actually I'm going to talk about images
just after okay so okay dates you can
learn the solution on data's where
random bro yeah it's fine okay
images so images this will take a little
bit of time so I'm not going to train to
take four minutes to train this this so
I'm not going to do it I'm going to grab
something that is already somewhere I'll
put it in notebook great so here you
have a bunch of low resolution images
already learned the distribution and now
let's do some samples yeah some sample
for the image I think they look pretty
although that not very realized
realistic and this is because it's is
just you know classic in that case it's
actually multi normal that would be the
best so it's not an algorithm that is
not powerful enough to get realistic
image this is because obtaining
realistic image is a very very hard
problem so currently you would for
example train genera adversarial
generative address your network for you
know many hours to get something decent
and on a restricted setting not with
many variables
nevertheless it's already useful this
version is already useful for example
you can clearly distinguish which image
so here I have an image from the
training set and image from the test set
the samples from the distribution an
image from another data set another
random image and if I get the
probability of this you can see that
three measures of training set it 10 to
the power 2000 is 10 to the power almost
2000 from test set and from other set is
10 minus 600 and random
match is very very low at least a log
would be more readable in that case so
we can already clearly perform an animal
addictions task using the distribution
even though it doesn't give various
examples and we really hope in the
future to be able to have extremely read
it example even with a small amount of
data like like we will give here by the
use of of transfer learning but transfer
learning for learning institution it's
much harder than for unsupervised
learning foreign supervised learning you
just take a network you cut it you
create a feature extractor and you train
on top of that for distribution
you cannot just extract features the way
you want it has to be reversible for
example you can also do feature
extraction but if you extract all have
to be with that lots of information and
reversible and that's not something we
have at the moment
good reversible feature extractor there
could be all the way to the transfer
learning but they are really not as
straightforward but that's something I
really want us to figure out how to do
maybe with a reversible like there are
some neo networks that are reversible
and that people are used to train
distributions and hopefully we can use
this network to to create a nice
reversible feature extract all and that
would be I mean that's something I
haven't seen in any paper and I hope we
can do it well you can just give a few
pictures let's say 20 or 50 and actually
like I say cats or whatever and actually
learn or something there was not even in
the training set of this reversible in
your network and and I can actually
learn from small amount of sample and
give realistic dreamed image so to speak
but anyway this might take a bit of time
there was a question yeah maybe you can
see well but it's actually you know it's
actually
I mean what I meant is sample that
looked like the training set that's what
I met this don't really look like the
training set you know you know this like
lot of colors maybe from you from your
you know a lot of colors there's some
statistics that have been captured by it
but clearly there's a lot of missing
things okay then take sound sequence
well as I told before said there yet so
we don't support viable length data but
it will be in the in the in the
following version okay so I'm going to
talk very quickly because actually I
don't have that much time so these are
the methods that are inside them so you
have things like Moochie normal which is
really a Gaussian distribution thing
like Goshen mixtures so in that case if
you train that on this I Rosetta scent
will find two two normal distributions
contingency tables so it's some things
the most simple algorithm for
distribution which is just you kind of
separates variables into buckets and
then you count you can do a table of all
the counts kernel density estimation
decision tree so something that
partitions space by asking question to
the to the data readin VP is one of
these reversible Network so we did an
implementation it's very experimental
don't expect it's not part of the
automation so it's something you can
obtain if you want to try it maybe on
the data it works well who knows but but
again this is quite experimental and in
the future we hope would be able to to
to implement things like random forest
or record on your network based solution
to end all viable length data and other
methods you can you can see the list
here so I would like to talk a little
bit on automation I already mentioned
that in the talk so I can be fast it's
something very similar to classify and
predict right where we start with a set
of configuration then we train
configuration on small test sets or do
experiments and then we try to predict
how well would configuration by
configuration I mean methods and other
parameters how well would they work on
the final training set
and fortunately is many problem that
that came out when during this function
is that it's much more brittle than
unsupervised learning you have repeated
elements that can mess up things if you
have like repeated example even repeat
available to repeat itself for some
reason you can mess things you cannot do
talked about it before feature
extraction as easily and and so on and
some model you cannot compute the PDF
easily okay so that is for an instrument
so in the future we try to implement all
the methods of good feature extractor
for image sound and maybe text and n as
also it was as before be able to do
transformation distribution such as
marginalizing or conditioning and there
is this future function we hope to to be
able to implement things to learn
distribution okay thank you very much
[Applause]